Japanese folklore has a vast selection
of urban legends and supernatural
entities to choose from today we'll
examine some of the weirdest and
creepiest tales it has to offer we begin
with one of the craziest pieces of
folklore that I've come across
Etan mermen a long narrow sheet of cloth
that is normally used to make clothes
seemingly harmless the cloth becomes
reanimated by a spirit native to the
region of Kagoshima and there are
reports of them flying through the sky
at night attacking people they would
attack people by wrapping themselves
around the person's face and neck
strangling and smothering them to death
they are often malicious and dangerous
spirits more than just simply
mischievous
there are many origin stories to hit
Daniel men one of the most common be and
when a person dies the kimono is sold to
someone else if the deceased is not able
to pass on upon death their spirit will
return and haunt the kimono
teka teka is a ghost that features in
many urban legends it is the spirit of a
woman who has suffered a horrific
accident having fallen onto the railroad
tracks
she was hit by an oncoming train the
impact caused her body to be torn in
half at the waist she did not die
instantly and was left to suffer a slow
and agonizing death she carries a scythe
or a sword and roams the train stations
of Japan crawling along the ground on
her hands and elbows making a tech tech
tech a sound anyone who is unfortunate
enough to come across teka teka will be
disembodied having their torso sawn in
half to mimic her own disfigurement she
goes by many other names including
batterbatter
and click-clack in the American version
of the urban legend according to the
legend
three days after here in this tale you
will encounter the ghost of a woman with
no lower half I can only hope that you
are forced enough to outrun teka teka
become a tight Qi mean in sickle
weasel-like their name suggests they are
weasels with claws as long and sharp as
sickles their furs made from spines
similar to that of a hedgehog
they are lightning-fast and invisible to
the naked eye they can ride swirling
whirl winds and have been known to come
and go with the wind become a tie to
travel in packs of three and often
appear from nowhere to viciously attack
their victims they have been known to
attack interns with the first slash in
the victims legs causing them to drop to
the ground
the second unleashing a barrage of a
thousand brutal cuts and the third
hamachi applies a magical salv that
heals the majority of the victims wounds
because of the speed of the attacks and
the hidden selves the victim cannot
perceive what has happened to them from
their perspective they have tripped
resulting in a few scratches and bruises
The Legend of the Tomica Chi is one that
you can find in all regions of Japan and
remains a popular explanation for
accidents that happen throughout the
country
Japanese culture is filled of creepy and
just outright weird folklore and there
is no doubt that we will be back
examining more in the near future if
you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained